GOOD AFTERNOON WOULD LIKE TO
CALL TO ORDER THE YOU STILL IT
UTILITY ENERGY AND COMMITTEE
HEARING.
A WE ARE SHORT OF A QUORUM AT
THE MOMENT -- BUT WE WILL START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THEN WHEN WE WILL.
TRANSITION ONCE WE HAVE A A
QUORUM PRESENT -- MISTER BIGELOW
WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE YOU -- YOUR
FILE ITEM.
A NUMBER THREE BUT WE APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING HERE -- AND JUST FOR
HOUSEKEEPING PURPOSES OF EDUARDO
GARCIA IS ABSENT TODAY -- AND
MAJORITY LEADER -- CALDERON WILL
BE FILLING IN AND HAS A PLACE.
AND THEN WE HAVE ONE ITEM.
THAT SHOWS ON CALENDAR -- ITEM
FOR A. B..
NINE EIGHTY THREE WARNER --
HORVATH -- THAT'S OFF CALENDAR
AND THAT WILL BE HELD AS A TO
YOUR BILL [inaudible]
WITH -- AND SO THAT'S WHAT IS TO
SHARE WITH EVERYONE AND SO --
WILL TURN TO YOU MISTER BIGELOW
I WILL TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND THEN WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE WILL -- WE GET A MOTION AND
WE'LL GO FROM THERE THANK YOU
FOR YOURS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE
TO PRESENT AB.
EIGHT SIX EIGHT WHICH CODIFIES
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
PROTOCOLS DURING A VOLUNTARY DE
ENTERED J. AT THE ENTERED CHAI'S
STATION.
HAT'S A BIG WORD.
YEAH BY HANNAH LECTER
CORPORATION AS WE ALL KNOW
ELECTRIC UTILITIES ARE
INCREASINGLY DE ENERGIZING
ELECTRICAL GRIDS AS A WILDFIRE
MITIGATION TOOL.
WELL THE DE ENERGIZED STATION
HAS PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE IT
ULTIMATELY LEADS CUSTOMERS IN
THE DARK LITERALLY AND
FIGURATIVELY.
MEMBERS THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILLHAVE PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE
DURING THE A PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF.
AS VOLUNTARY POWER SHUT OFF
BECOME OUR NEW NORMAL IT'S
IMPERATIVE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES SCHOOLS HOSPITALS.
AND MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE PROVIDED
CERTAINTY WITH CONSISTENT
RELIABLE COMMUNICATION WHENEVER
POSSIBLE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF AND THE STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
WITH ME MISTER CHAIRMAN TODAY IS
MISTER BOB REAP.
REPRESENTING THE ELDORADO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT -- FOR SOME
SUPPORT TESTIMONY OR HE HAS SOME
WORDS -- PREPARED IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO HAVE WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT BUT SINCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM CALL THE ROLL ABSOLUTELY
ESTABLISH OR SO.
BROKE UP WITH HOLDEN.
PRESENT PATTERSON [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK HERE.
REYES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
OKAY WE'LL HEAR FROM YOUR
WITNESS MOVING THIS WONDERFUL
BILL.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN US AS
AMENDED SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BABRI
BUT WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF ELDORADO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT THE SPONSOR
OF THE MEASURE.
LAST SUMMER WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
IN ITS CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WAS
DISCUSSING -- THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF AS AND AS A PART
OF THE BROADER ISSUES
SURROUNDING WILD FIRE MITIGATION
AND PREVENTION PLANNING.
WE WE TRIED TO BRING FORWARD THE
THE IMPACTS THAT FALL ON WATER
AND WASTEWATER SYSTEMS AS A
RESULT OF THE P. S. P. S.
OCCURRENCES [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
ABOUT -- TWO HUNDRED SQUARE
MILES OF SERVICE TERRITORY
BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
FOUR THOUSAND FOOT ELEVATION
IT'S UP IN THE FOOT HILLS TO THE
EAST OF HERE.
AND SO WE RELY ON A LOT OF LIVE
STATIONS.
THAT ARE.
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE SERVICE
AREA WE ALSO RELY ON REFILLING
OUR STORAGE TANKS -- THAT PUT
PRESSURE INTO THE SYSTEM THAT
SUPPORT FIRE HYDRANTS AND
DRINKING WATER.
WHEN THE POWER SHUT OFF WE HAVE
A BIG PROBLEM?
NUMBER ONE THE WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS DON'T OPERATE CAPACITY SO
YOU CAN ONE CAN IMAGINE IF
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF AUGUST
ON A HUNDRED AND TEN DAY THAT'S
WHEN THE IN THE POWER GET SHUT
OFF.
WE LOSE DRINKING WATER WE LOSE
THE ABILITY TO REFILL OUR
STORAGE TANKS WE LOSE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE SURE THOSE FIRE
HYDRANTS ARE OPERATIONAL.
SIMILARLY ON THE WASTE WATER
SIDE WHEN THE POWER SET OFF WE
CAN'T LIVE THE SEWAGE. TO GET TO
THE TREATMENT PLANT AND WHEN WE
HAVE SEWAGE BACKING UP IT COMES
OUT IN DIFFERENT.
PLACES IN THE LOWER PARTS OF THE
SYSTEM PEOPLE'S HOMES A MAN
HOLES WEEK WE HAVE THE RISK OF
OVER FLOWS INTO CREEKS AND
RIVERS UP THERE.
SO IT'S A REAL CONCERN FOR US WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SENDS A CLEAR SIGNAL
TO THE ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
THAT THEY NEED TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE WATER AND WASTEWATER
UTILITIES.
AND WORK ON PROTOCOLS AND AND
WAYS TO EITHER AVOID OR MITIGATE
THESE POTENTIAL PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPACTS WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK AND REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I WILL TAKE -- JUST ME
TUESDAY OUT IF WE COULD -- IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NIKOLINA NONE OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC AS PART.
VALERIE CHILDHOOD -- SPECIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE ELSE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL IS
THERE ANY.
OR ANY WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
IN OTHER COMMENTS.
YES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON REVIEW AND
AMENDMENTS IN THE FOUR TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
WONDERFUL.
OKAY WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
JUST ONE POINT OF CLARIFICATION
THE AUTHOR DID ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU LAST
STATEMENT THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION HAS BEEN
SECONDED ROLL CALL. TWELVE
UNLESS YOU'D LIKE A ALL EXCEPT
ALL OF THAT IS MY CLOTHES ARE A
VERY GOOD THING.
AB EIGHT SIX EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HI PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I GEN.
AND I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I CALDERON.
CALDERON HI MAYES.
MAIDS I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
RADIUS.
AS I SAID TA GO [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
THE YOUR BILL HAS -- ENOUGH
CLOSE TO MOVE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS.
SIR SECOND SEVENTY OKAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL OF THE ROLL CALL
ON CONSENT.
THIS IS -- I A. B..
TEN FIFTY FOUR AB CHEN FIFTY FOR
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI.
HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I GEN.
GEN HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I CALDERON.
CALDERON HI MAYES.
MAYES I CITY YOUR CITY I QUIRK
ARE CORRECT HI AREAS.
REYES I SANTEE SAN DIEGO.
SANTIAGO EXCUSE ME TEEN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WE'RE LOOKING [inaudible]
FOR OKAY AUTHORS.
COME ON UP.
WELCOME TO YOU HERE TO PRESENT
ON A. B..
TEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD SUPPORT LOCAL SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
EFFORTS TO INSTALL COST
EFFECTIVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECT THE BILL SECOND.
THANK YOU I AM THE SOLE EXTENT
OF COURSE OUR OUR SUCCESSFUL
WORK UNDER PROP -- THIRTY NINE
TO CUT GREENHOUSE GASES AND PUT
GOOD PEOPLE TO WORK.
AT LAST NIGHT.
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS YOUR FIRST
WITNESS DAVE ALL WRAPPED
REPRESENTING SCHOOL ENERGY
COMMISSION -- COALITION.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ENERGY IS THE
SECOND LARGEST EXPENDITURE AFTER
PEOPLE TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
FREE UP MONEY FOR CLASSROOM
EXPENDITURES THIS IS VERY VERY
HELPFUL.
AND IT HELPS.
IN REDUCING DEMAND TO MEET OUR
PIANO VOCALS.
WE AREN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND THE PAST TO LABOR.
YES PLEASE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH CURLY
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIUM AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
STERN MEMBERS THE NVIDIA WITH
THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE HEARING ON WILL TURN
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A MOTION -- TO DO PASS.
GRADUATION IS TO LABOR.
HOWEVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AND IF YOU LIKE.
I'VE GOT SOME TIME TO BURN UP I
MEAN WE GET WE CAN SIT AND TALK
ABOUT HOW HOW GREAT IT IS TO
HAVE A PROGRAM THAT.
NOT ONLY CAN PROVIDE GOOD LIVING
WAGE JOBS WITH BENEFITS BUT ALSO.
REDUCE THE COST IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND CONTINUE AB MEETING ARE
TRYING TO MEET OUR OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS.
EMISSION GOALS AND SO -- IT'S A
WIN WIN WIN WE DON'T GET A LOT
OF THOSE.
SHOULD.
A ROLL CALL.
TV TEN TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
BURKE.
CARILLO. THREE I'D CHEN.
CHEN HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I CALDERON.
CALDERON HI MAYES.
MAYES I CG.
CG AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE REYES.
I THINK DIEGO [inaudible]
IN.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON
WE WERE WAITING.
FOR THIS RUBIO AND WAR MR
SANTIAGO
.
IT WAS IMPORTANT [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH -- YEAH
[inaudible]
APPLE [inaudible]
HELLO.
I WOULD SAY ABOUT A THIS RUBIO
WELCOME -- WE'RE HERE -- TO HERE
YOUR PRESENTATION ON A BEFORE.
NINETY ONE THANK YOU I WAS
NUMBER ONE IN ANOTHER COMEDIAN
NUMBER ONE HERE TO SOLVE THE
KITCHEN I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
PATIENT -- I THINK I KNOW WHAT
YOUR BILL HAS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS GOT IT.
GOT IT.
I DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU AVAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M PRESENTING ITS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR NINETY ONE A MEASURE
CANNELLA CONCERNING THE
POTENTIAL USE OF HYDROGEN
CONCENTRATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING -- THIS SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED IN
OUR COMMENTS TO AND COMMENT FOR
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS MEASURE.
CALIFORNIA HAS CONTINUOUSLY SET
STANDARDS FOR REDUCING CARBON%
EMISSIONS AND IS A LEADER FOR
RENEWABLE ENERGY PRODUCTION.
WELL CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTALLY CONSCIOUS IT IS
ALL IT ALSO EMITS THE SECOND
MOST TO GREENHOUSE GASES OUT OF
ALL FIFTY STATES.
REDUCING GREENHOUSE EMISSIONS
WITH WITHOUT CRIPPLING OUR
ENERGY SECTOR IS A DIFFICULT AND
COMPLEX TAX.
TASK THAT IS CONTINUOUSLY BEING
ADDRESSED BY OUR SEATS --
BRIGHTEST MINDS OF THE PROMISING
ENERGY SOURCES OF CARBON
NEUTRALITY HYDROGEN HAS IMMENSE
POTENTIAL AND REDUCING OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
HYDROGEN IS A HIGHLY EN EL
ENERGETIC MONOCLE MOLECULE THAT
IS NOT ONLY CARBON FREE BUT ALSO
RENEWABLE.
I IN 201730% OF THE US ENERGY
CONSUMPTION WAS DELIVERED VIA
NATURAL GAS.
NATURAL GAS INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
BEEN DEVELOPED INTHE U. S. OVER
DECADES OF INVESTMENT AND
COMPLEX PLANNING. TO DEVELOP AN
EQUIVALENT SYSTEM BY HYDROGEN
WOULD BE EXCESSIVELY EXPENSIVE
AND NOT REALISTIC WITH CURRENT
MEANS TO PROVIDE HYDROGEN TO
STATE TO A STATE OF MORE THAN
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
HOWEVER PROMISING RESEARCH HAS
ALSO ALREADY BEEN STARTED AND
IMPLEMENTED IN SEVERAL EUROPEAN
NATIONS DEMONSTRATING THE
EFFICACY OF USING EXISTING
NATURAL GAS LINES FOR HYDROGEN
DISTRIBUTION UP TO
CONCENTRATIONS OF 20%.
BECAUSE NATURAL GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY BY LOCATION.
THE EFFECTS OF BLENDING IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRING ASSESSMENT
BASE.
AND THAT'S THAT'S MEANT BASED ON
OUR EXISTING SYSTEMS AB FOR
NINETY ONE WILL COME A WILL
COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY TO PROCURE A STUDY
THAT ASSESSES THE IMPACT OF
BLENDING HYDROGEN.
INTO EXISTING NATURAL GAS
PIPELINE WITH CONCENTRATIONS UP
220%.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE TIM
CARMICHAEL ON BEHALF OF SEMPRA
ENERGY THE SPONSOR OF AB -- FOUR
NINETY ONE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
GERALD IN A BRIEF STATEMENT A
TIM CARMICHAEL SEMPRA ENERGY
UTILITIES -- FIRST TO THANK YOU
THE AUTHOR FOR CARRYING THIS
MEASURE AS WE DISCUSSED WITH
MANY OF YOU -- WE BELIEVE HAS
CALIFORNIA INCREASES IT'S
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO -- THERE'S A
GROWING AWARENESS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE ADEQUATE ENERGY STORAGE
CAPACITY WE THINK HUNDRED HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BE PART OF THAT
SOLUTION.
WE ALSO SEE A GROWING AWARENESS --
AND OUR COMPANY BELIEVES
STRONGLY IN.
EFFORTS TO DE CARBONIZED THE
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM AND WE SEE
HYDROGEN PLAYING A ROLE IN THAT
AS IT HAS IN EUROPE -- WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN GALLERY TO
RELIVE Là HOST PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY. FOR THE
REASONS ALREADY STATED WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK.
NEED A CUP FOR COALITION FOR ANY
OF THE NATURAL GAS WE ARE
SUPPORT ALSO SUSTAINABLE AND
USES OF RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
INCLUDING AT THE PRODUCTION OF
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN SO WE AT URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TO A THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON GAS
ELECTRICITY -- CRANKS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HANDLE IT I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF BLOOM ENERGY IN
SUPPORT.
HI ALLIGATOR ON BEHALF OF ENERGY
WE ALSO SUPPORT.
AND MICHAEL BOOKER ON BEHALF OF
A CA WE ARE NOT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WE ARE ALSO NOT IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION.
WE HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS TO
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND TO THE
SPONSOR WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
COST IMPLICATION LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL BEEFED UP.
NOT LOOKING JUST THE COST OF
PRODUCING HYDROGEN BUT THE COST
IMPLICATIONS FOR RATEPAYERS AS
MANY OF YOU'VE ALL SEEN PROBABLY
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS SO
CAL GAS IS MADE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENT IT'S ABOUT BECOMING
THE CLEANEST.
GAS UTILITY IN THE COUNTRY BY
PUTTING 20% RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS IN THE PIPELINE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT 20% HYDROGEN IN THE
PIPELINE BOTH ARE IN G. AND
HYDROGEN ARE EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE AND SO THE COST
IMPLICATIONS ON RATE PAYERS NEED
TO BE WELL UNDERSTOOD.
IT'S NOT SIMPLY ABOUT PUTTING
THIS RENEWABLE GAS INTO THE
PIPELINE IF IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
COMPETITIVE FOR OUR LARGE
AGRICULTURAL AND INDUSTRIAL
CUSTOMERS SO WE'D LIKE TO GET
SOME FURTHER AMENDMENTS THAT
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT THE COST
IMPLICATIONS THANK YOU.
RESPECT THAT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE WHO
HAS A IN BETWEEN POSITION OR NO
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
YES WE ARE MISTER.
THE QUESTION WITH RESPECT -- TO
THE COST THAT WAS JUST RAISED --
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT.
A BET I MEAN I I I REPRESENT A
LOT OF FOLKS THAT.
OUR HI AG ELECTRICITY USERS --
BUTTON.
HELP HELP US OUT UNDERSTANDING.
THE COST QUESTION THAT WAS
RAISED HERE.
SO.
WE ALSO CARE A LOT ABOUT THE
COST IF IT IF IT DOESN'T PENCIL
OUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THEN
IT'S NOT REALLY A VIABLE
SOLUTION -- ONE OF THE BIG
CHANGE IS HAPPENING IN OUR WORLD
TODAY AT LEAST IN THE UNITED
STATES IS WE NOT ONLY HAVE A A
GROWING RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO WE
HAVE EXCESS.
RENEWABLE ENERGY BEING GENERATED
AND THE VISION FOR COST
EFFECTIVE HYDROGEN REALIZE QUITE
A BIT ON THAT EXCESS RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO -- BEING AVAILABLE TO
GENERATE VERY LOW COST OR FREE.
ENERGY WHEN THE REST OF THE
GREAT DOESN'T NEED IT.
I WE SEE THAT AS A BIG PART OF
THE COST CONTROL COSTS
MANAGEMENT FOR THE HYGIENE PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE.
ON FORMER ENERGY SECRETARY CHU
ACTUALLY AS A PIECE OUT.
TODAY OR YESTERDAY SPEAKING TO
THIS ON A NATIONAL SCALE -- SO I
THINK CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN THE LEAD ON
THIS IN A MINUTE IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT OTHERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE TAKING A GOOD LOOK
AT IT [inaudible]
TOO OKAY.
APPRECIATE THAT SO IF THERE ARE
NO OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL ON THEM --
I'M SORRY. FOR YOUR CALL FOR IN
BETWEEN POSITIONS AND NO
POSITIONS ARE NOT OPPOSITE MY
APOLOGIES NO PROBLEM -- LAUREN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE OF A. B. --
FOR NINETY ONE WE BELIEVE THAT
IN ORDER FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET
ITS CLIMB AND GREENHOUSEGAS
REDUCTION TARGETS THE STATE MUST
STOP RELYING ON ITS NATURAL GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE IDEA OF USING HYDROGEN AN
EXISTING NATURAL GRASS GRID HAS
BEEN ANALYZED IN VERY STUDIES
GOING BACK TO THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
THIS RESEARCH HAS ALREADY
DISCLOSE THE DANGERS ASSOCIATED
WITH INJECTING HYDROGEN INTO THE
PIPELINES HYDROGEN IS A SMALLER
MOLECULES IN GAS GIVING IT A
FASTER LEE COULD TRADE IN A MORE
POTENT CORROSIVE EFFECT ON
METALS.
BLENDING HUNDRED AND CAN
MATERIAL DEGREE MATERIAL THE TO
GRADE PIPELINES DESIGN FOR
NATURAL GAS THIS HYDROGEN
EMBRITTLEMENT OF THE PIPING
LEADS TO A HIGHER RISK OF
DANGEROUS LEAKS.
WE DO NOT WANT TO EXTEND THE
TIME PERIOD FOR WHICH CALIFORNIA
ITS ENVIRONMENT AND COMMUNITIES
WILL BE SUBJECTED TO PIPELINE
LEAKS.
AGAIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MUST PHASE OUT THE USE OF
NATURAL GAS INFRASTRUCTURE.
TIME AND EFFORT SHOULD BE SPENT
ON GETTING US OFF PUTTING GAS
ENTIRELY WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
TRUE CLEAN RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES LIKE WIND AND SOLAR IN
ORDER TO MEET OUR TARGETS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
THIS ROUTE -- THIS RECIPE.
THANK YOU AND WITH THE COMMENTS
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB I THINK OF
A GREAT CONCERNED ESPECIALLY
WITH WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
IS THIS THE THE THE IS A IN
THEIR STATEMENT THEY TALKED
ABOUT A HIGHER RISK OF CORROSION
AND LEAKS.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT CONCERN.
WELL THAT'S THE POINT OF THE
BILL THAT WE ARE --
COMMISSIONING THE CALIFORNIA C.
COUNTY COUNCIL SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY TO DO THE STUDY AND
SO IF THAT'S THE CASE WE'RE NOT.
IMPLEMENTING ANYTHING THIS IS
JUST PACIFIC LEAD TO GET A STUDY
TO SEE WHERE WE ARE YES THERE
HAS BEEN OTHER.
ACCORDING TO WHAT SHE SAID --
STUDIES ALL THIS STUDY WOULD
GIVE US THAT INFORMATION OF
CURRENT INFORMATION -- IN REAL
TIME AND SO THIS IS JUST THE
STUDY AND IF IT DOESN'T BOB.
PENCIL OUT AND IT DOESN'T -- BUT
THIS IS SPECIFICALLY FOR STUDY.
IF IF I MAY UM IF A STUDY HAS
BEEN DONE WOULD YOU WORK WITH
SHARE CLUB TO SEE WHAT THE STUDY
WITH THE SCOPE OF THAT STUDY WAS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY CAUSING
A DANGER THAT WE WE STEER AWAY
FROM THAT -- BECAUSE CERTAINLY
NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE THESE LEAKS
IN THEIR COMMUNITY ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
OF THIS MESSAGE THANK YOU -- I
HAVE TO ADMIT I DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH ABOUT.
TO HYDROGEN COULD YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW HYDROGEN IS -- RENEWABLE.
SO TODAY -- HYDROGEN IS PRODUCED
IN AT LEAST THREE DIFFERENT WAYS --
FROM FOSSIL NATURAL GAS BY YOU
PUT IT THROUGH A PROCESS YOU
MOVE THE CARBON AND YOU'VE GOT
HODGEN.
YOU CAN TAKE ANY -- ORGANIC
BASED RENEWABLE GAS FROM A
GETTING WAY STREAM COULD BE.
ORGANIC MATERIALS COMING OUT OF
URBAN AREAS COULD BE
AGRICULTURAL ORGANIC WASTE
SIMILAR PROCESS REMOVE THE
CARBON YOU GOT HIGH JIM LEFT
OVER.
THE THIRD PROCESS WHICH HAS GOT
A LOT OF ATTENTION RECENTLY IS
WHAT'S CALLED ELECTROLYTIC --
HYDROGEN WHICH IS BACK TO OUR
HIGH SCHOOL CHEMISTRY CLASS
WHERE YOU RUN ELECTRIC CURRENT
THROUGH A A JAR OF WATER AND
THAT CREATES OXYGEN AND HYDROGEN.
YOU CAN DO THAT ON A ON A LARGER
SCALE.
BACK TO MR PATTERSON'S QUESTION
ABOUT COST IF YOU'RE ELECTRICITY
IS VERY LOW COST OR FREE THAT
PROCESS STARTS TO BECOME.
MORE AND MORE ECONOMICAL -- SO
ALL THREE OF THOSE ARE IN PLAY
TODAY AND WE AS A COMPANY AND AS
A SECTOR.
INTERESTED IN DEVELOPING HODGEN
THINK THAT ALL THREE SHOULD.
UNDERGO FURTHER DEVELOPMENT.
AND ALL THREE ARE EQUALLY AT
THIS POINT COMMERCIALLY VIABLE.
TODAY MOST HYGIENIST PRODUCED
FROM A A FOSSIL GAS BUT IT'S THE
SAME TECHNOLOGY.
AND PROCESS.
FOR PRODUCING IT FROM OUR NOBLE
GAS AND ON THE ELECTROLYTIC IT
IS.
A EARLY IN THE PROCESS OF
GROWING THAT TO SCALE FOR
COMMERCIAL USE MORE THAN YOU
KNOW TAKING BASICALLY FROM THE
LAB OF THE PROJECT TWO YES WE
CAN REPLICATE THIS ACROSS THE
STATE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
IS FOR REAL YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY THIS SAYS A DO PASSED TO
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT I'M SORRY --
THE PAST -- TO CORPORATIONS AS
AMENDED THANK YOU [inaudible]
BROKE UP.
AB FOUR NINETY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN HI HOLDEN
HIGH PATTERSON PATTERSON I BURKE
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
CHEN.
CHEN HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
IN A GARCIA I CALDERON.
CALDERON HI MAYES.
MAYES I MERCI GI YOUR CITY I
KIRK QUIRK AYE QUIRK HI.
YES [inaudible]
SANTIAGO MY SANTIAGO AYE TEEN.
OF THE MOTION PASSES OTHER
COMMITTEE CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE REALLY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
OKAY MISTER SANTIAGO EUROPE.
THANK YOU MISTER SB.
FIVE SIXTY AND YOU ENJOY A DO
PASS TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT.
HAVEN'T HEARD THAT COMMENT WITH
THE CHAIR.
APPRECIATE BREVITY [inaudible]
THE BILL.
AB FIVE SIXTY WILL ENSURE THAT
TAX PAYER US OUR RATE PAYER
DOLLARS ARE NOT USED BY THE TWO
UTILITIES. TO FAVOR OR OPPOSE A
UNIQUE TO THESE -- WITH NAV ONE
WITNESS -- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MONNA GONNA BE HALF
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AND SO MISTER SANTIAGO STATED
IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE.
PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR THIS BILL
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION -- ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING NONE SANTIAGO WHICH
ELECTED.
RESPECT LAST RIVALS ARE OKAY
ROLL CALL THE MOTION.
AB FIVE SIXTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE PATTERSON
PATTERSON HI BURKE.
CARILLO CHEN.
CHEN HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I CALDERON.
CALDERON HI MAYES MAYES I CITY
HIGH MURATSUCHI I WORK I WORK HI
REYES.
SANTIAGO I THINK.
SANTIAGO HI TEEN.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU AND WE
WILL NOW GO BACK.
AND TRY TO CATCH SOME OF THE
MEMBERS UP ON ANY BILLS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN VOTED ON LET'S
START AT THE TOP OF THE WE ARE
[inaudible]
SO WITH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
START START AT THE TOP OF MY AB.
FOUR NINETY ONE CALLING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BURKE. THIRTY RAY S.
[inaudible]
TEEN.
AB.
FIVE SIXTY CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO -- RARE AS TEAM
[inaudible]
A. B.. EIGHT SIX EIGHT CALLING
ABSENT MEMBERS.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I IN TEAM.
AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT COLIN ABSENT
MEMBERS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I EIGHTEEN
AS MAYBE -- TEN FIFTY FOUR
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS PATTERSON
ANDERSON AYE BURKE [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
SANTIAGO HI THIAGO HIGH TEEN.
CAN.
TEND TO GET INTO THE PLOT.
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN HI.
OKAY -- CRITICAL BACK AROUND FOR
YOU.
REVISITING -- AB FOR NINETY ONE
TING.
OKAY CENTRAL -- TO AB FIVE SIXTY
TING [inaudible]
TING I AB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT TING.
TING I AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT TEEN
HEART TING I AND OKAY.
WITH THAT.
I WILL WAIT TO VOTE. FIVE
MINUTES FOR HIS WORK TO COME IN
AND ADD ON AND THEN WE WILL
ADJOURN.
IT'S RARE FOR ALSO CONTAINING
ANYWAY SHE STILL HAS THAT ON AS
WELL [inaudible]
SALAS RICINUS.
THE DIFFERENCE IS [inaudible]
IT'S THE REST.
THE SERVICE IN YOUR OF YOUR
FRIEND IS IT'S GOING TO TAKE SHE
WAS SHE WAS [inaudible]
DIFFERENT [inaudible]
YEAH.
RIGHT NOW OKAY [inaudible]
HELLO NOT -- OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH
--
SO WHAT.
LET'S CIRCLE BACK SANTIAGO REAL
OKAY. FOUR NINETY ONE THIS IS
THE LAST.
DAY OKAY.
WE'LL JUST FLY BACK THROUGH THE
ONES THAT YOU HAVE NOT.
AB. FOR NINETY ONE READ.
ON RED SIGN.
AB FIVE SIXTY RAY S.
[inaudible]
YES I
OKAY.
AB FOUR NINETY ONE BURKE.
BURKE HI.
AB.
FIVE SIXTY BURKE I AB. EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT BURKE BURKE I AB TEN
TWENTY EIGHT BURKE.
BURKE I AND AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
BURKE.
BURKE HI [inaudible]
NOW.
THIS.
IS.
TOTAL.
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
AB [inaudible]
FOR NINETY ONE CARILLO.
I THAT HAS FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE
HAS FOURTEEN BOTH AND IF I'LL --
AB FIVE SIXTY CARILLO.
CARRY ON MY AND THAT MEASURE HAS
[inaudible] FIFTEEN GO. FIFTEEN
NUMBER FIFTEEN BOTH IN AN
MEASURES OUT.
AB EIGHT SIX EIGHT HAS FIFTEEN
BOTH THAT MEASURES OUT.
YEAH.
AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT HAS FIFTEEN
VOTES IN THAT MEASURE IS OUT
[inaudible]
IN.
WELL IN A BE I TEN FIFTY FOUR
HAS. FOURTEEN BOTH IN ITSELF.
ON THE GET YOUR OKAY.
EVERYONE THIS MAN IS ADJOURNED
.
THERE WAS A BIG [inaudible]
YEAH.
I GREW UP.
RIGHT.
SOME PEOPLE MAKE NO
[inaudible]
YEAH
JERRY